you're watching Disney Channel and
you're watching Disney Channel
hi I'm annalisa from maxsa Raven and
you're watching Disney Channel
[Music]
hi I'm Kirsten storms from Dion and you
watching Disney Channel's
[Music]
hey I'm just removing the wire and
you're watching Disney check
[Music]
I'm Tia and I'm Tamera Mowry from Sister
Sister and you're watching Disney
Channel
I'm Tasha Maurice marketing and you're
watching Disney Channel
hi i'm america ferrera and we gotta keep
it up and you're watching Disney tail
[Music]
hey what's up its christy carlson romano
you're watching Disney Channel
[Music]
hey what's up I'm Miley Cyrus from
Hannah Montana and you are watching
Disney Channel
hi I'm Selena Gomez from Wizards of
Waverly Place and you are watching
Disney Channel No thank you
[Music]
please
[Music]
like that
hi I'm Brenda song and you're watching
Disney Channel
[Music]
hey there where the Jonas Brothers from
the Disney Channel Original Series Jonas
you're watching Disney Channel
hi I'm trying to am a claim for ant farm
and you're watching Disney Channel
[Music]
all right hi I'm Ross Lynch from Austin
now and you're watching Disney Channel
[Music]
hey what's up its and daya from Casey
undercover and you're watching Disney
Channel
looking good
[Music]